ó olhar para um espaço tão inspirador e
especial e perceber que não sou o único
é uma sensação que nunca tinha tido de
verdade até hoje eu nunca tinha visto
ninguém com a mesma cor da minha pele
sentar numa mesa de reuniões comigo e
vocês me fizeram acreditar que é só uma
questão de tempo
esse é um dos vários depoimentos que eu
escuto todos os dias dos jovens que
trabalham comigo nessa minha curta
trajetória eu já vi muita gente desistir
dos sonhos por causa da cor da pele por
causa da idade
por ser mulher ou até pelo curso que fez
na faculdade e você já desistiu de algum
sonho por causa desses rótulos
eu tenho aprendido na prática a
importância ea dificuldade de romper com
esses rótulos
eu como mulher filé de nordestinos que
batalharam muito na vida já tinha um
caminho traçado para dar certo
ou ia ser médica ou e advogada
imagina a felicidade dos meus pais
quando eu falei que ia fazer psicologia
é imaginário deles assim como acho que
muita gente até hoje
ou ia morrer de fome ou essa faculdade
não ia dar em nada
naquela época ainda não tinha muita
consciência mas foi o início de um
processo de entender como ele lidava com
as expectativas das outras pessoas o
quanto das minhas decisões de fato eram
minhas ou eram decisões para agradar os
outros e eu precisava mostrar para as
pessoas que mesmo fazendo a psicologia
eu podia dar certo na vida
então comecei a trabalhar desde o
primeiro ano de faculdade e foi nos
recursos humanos que encontrei meu
espaço
eu sempre gostei muito de trabalhar com
pessoas e apoiar elas ainda enxergar o
que ela chama de melhor
aliás foi isso que me levou pra
psicologia também e quando eu escolhi o
recurso - também foi para apoiar esses
processos dentro das organizações
e este caminho durante muito tempo fez
sentido pra mim e deve ter sido por isso
que algumas situações que tinham vivido
foram tão difíceis de enxergar
eu ouvia coisas como nossas é tão
novinha incompetente para benzing ou eu
achei que era daquelas psicólogas que
abraça árvore mas me surpreendi
aí eu não sabia se ficava em silêncio ou
se eu agradecia por que as pessoas
falavam isso com tom de elogio mas o que
me dará de fato de eu ser nova tinha a
ver com fazer um bom trabalho ou porque
pessoas mais jovens não podiam ser chefe
de pessoas mais velhas ocupa cargos mais
altos e o fato da psicóloga
quantas vezes já não foi questionada
sobre a minha capacidade analítica ou de
entender de negócios porque eu vim de
uma área de humanas
então foi muito difícil enxergar e
perceber que tudo isso eram rótulos e
principalmente não foi rápido saber com
romper quando trabalhava numa grande
multinacional eu cuidava do processo do
programa de estágio e eu sempre gostei
muito de trabalhar com jovens apoiar
eles enxergar essas motivações seus
sonhos porque estavam ali mas ao mesmo
tempo processo seletivo me intrigava
muito eu não entendia porque a gente
tinha que ter uma idade limite para se
inscrever ou porque a gente só aceitava
administração engenharia para umas
posições ou porque só a faculdade a e b
eram boas o suficiente e foi
questionando essas situações que eu
consegui questionar os meus próprios
rótulos
eu fui me conscientizando que não é
porque eu tinha 22 anos e muitas vezes
era mais nova de uma sala de reunião que
a minha opinião não podia ser ungido não
era o fato de eu ser mulher que
permitirá que as pessoas
interrompesse enquanto estava falando
então de novo não vai ser fácil e mesmo
vai ser rápido vamos ver com esses
rótulos que ele está muito enraizado na
gente desde que a gente nasce da
maternidade já sai com um kit rótulo
para o resto da vida
mas nessa época não queria pensar muito
sobre isso eu achava que o incômodo
vinha muito mais porque eu trabalhava
com processo seletivo
então resolvi mudar e trabalhar com o
treinamento e desenvolvimento uma
consultoria
e aí eu cuidava desde os programas de
desenvolvimento dos treinos até os
programas de liderança dos diretores das
organizações
todos os dias me desafiava muito aprendi
alguma coisa nova mas aquela pulga do
incômodo continuava lá eu em várias
reuniões com clientes muito diferentes e
muitas vezes eu era uma das únicas
mulheres na sala e mesmo as mulheres que
estavam lá não eram elas que tomavam as
decisões finais
eu perdi as contas de quantas vezes eu
fui elogiada pela minha capacidade de
entender de business
mesmo sendo psicóloga não foi rápido
romper com esse processo
mas nessa época eu precisava dar certo
na vida então é deixar isso de lado e
focada no sucesso mesmo que nessa época
não soubesse muito bem o que era sucesso
pra mim mas eu olhava para um lado e os
amigos do colégio estavam ganhando muito
dinheiro no mercado financeiro ou
viajando o mundo um super feliz nas
escolhas que eles tinham feito
ou pelo menos era isso que as redes
sociais insistiam em mostrar todos os
dias nessa época minha vida toda certa
né
eu tinha um emprego legal eu ganhava bem
eu sabia onde eu ia tá daqui cinco anos
uma pergunta clássica de processo
seletivo
a vida estava toda certa
na verdade não tivesse toda errada
todo dia eu acordava irritada ela
irritada com os projetos e recatada com
rh agitada com os pássaros que o evento
contudo também estava com tudo mas na
verdade
eu não queria enxergar o que estava
acontecendo e não via mais sentido do
que estava fazendo
eu não via mais sentido meu trabalho na
forma como estava fazendo
então eu resolvi parar de ficar irritado
e fazer alguma coisa
como parte desse meu incômodo vinha do
trabalho e resolvi tirar um tempo para
estudar e fazer uma especialização
estados unidos
algumas pessoas vão interpretar isso
também como fuga mas aí já é outra
história
e quando eu decidi por estados unidos
eu tive três grandes aprendizados o
primeiro deles você tá com medo vai
comer do mesmo é não sabia sim e é dar
certo era o melhor momento de sair do
brasil naquela época seria ter emprego
quando eu voltasse eu parei de ficar
pensando e se esse e resolvi fazer
eu conversei com muita gente que já
tinha morado fora do país
eu pesquisei muito sobre os cursos que
eu queria fazer e eu me planejar
financeiramente e mesmo com medo eu
resolvi jogar e chegando lá eu tive uma
segunda grande aprendizado mudar nenhum
é fácil e não é indolor
eu cheguei num dos piores invernos
estados unidos e morava num apartamento
com um pouco mais de 10 metros quadrados
e todos os dias eram um mix de
sentimento de frustração de não
conseguir dar conta de solidão eo time
segurava todos os dias era até a
consciência que aquela decisão tinha
sido minho e lá todos os dias eu também
tinha novas fotos para romper como da
latina que só estava lá por diversão e
não foi fácil lidar com esse processo lá
também mas com o tempo fui me adaptando
conhecendo novas pessoas estudando indo
em vários eventos em um desses eventos
foi organizada por brasileiros que
estavam fora do brasil e o foco do
evento é mostrar por que aqueles
brasileiros deveriam voltar e
transformar o país e foi a primeira vez
isso que eu entrei em contato com
pessoas da política e da gestão pública
que de fato me inspiraram que de fato
estavam colocando a mão na massa pelo
nosso país
e aí eu saí de lá com um baita
sentimento de transformação de querer
voltar e fazer alguma coisa diferente e
aí quando eu voltei para o brasil e tive
o terceiro grande aprendizado
nem tudo são flores e nem sempre se
ganha uma copa do mundo
eu voltei no meio da copa de 2014 ea
minha sensação é que minha vida era um
grande site a 1
eu encontrava os amigos dos séculos mas
familiares e era sempre a mesma pergunta
e aí que tá fazendo aquela frustração de
não saber o que responder
mas com a certeza de que eu não queria
fazer qualquer coisa eu queria fazer
algo de fato fosse transformar o país
e aí eu queria transformar não adiantava
ficar sentada no sofá da minha casa eu
tinha que fazer alguma coisa então foi
uma época que conheci muita gente eu
tomei muito café sexta feira o dia
sagrado do café
eu conheci muita gente do impacto social
empreendedor amigo de amigo e muito
sobre o terceiro setor e fiz um trabalho
voluntário mas sempre bate aquela crise
existencial
será que tomei a decisão certa será que
não deveria estar na consultoria
ganhando dinheiro de novo o da não é
fácil eu precisei ter muita paciência
quando as oportunidades não vieram
eu preciso conhecer muita gente que
também estava passando por esse processo
de mudança e me planejar financeiramente
para o futuro
foi um processo de nove meses
praticamente uma gestação de uma nova
vida que escolhi pra mim é uma coisa
muito importante foi perceber que
durante muito tempo eu quis negar minha
trajetória
eu quis negar todo o meu passado com
recursos humanos porque eu achei que se
eu quisesse transformar o país tem que
ser com alguma coisa totalmente
diferente mas foi olhando para o passado
que eu consegui mirar o futuro e aí meus
caminhos
quanto mais claros e meio esses milhões
de cafés
eu conhecia já estou a copa que é
fundadora do vetor brasil e ela me falou
eu estou fazendo essa organização
eu não sei se vai dar certo eu não sei
se ela vai existir daqui um mês
mas eu preciso muito de alguém que
entenda de pessoas
você topa fazer isso junto comigo e cair
tom e empreendendo vetor brasil com a
certeza absoluta que a gente já está
transformando o brasil com uma rede de
pessoas que são engajados e são diversas
e transformam o setor público por dentro
hoje nosso principal programa um trainee
gestão pública que a gente atrás
seleciona e desenvolve pessoas que vão
trabalhar em secretarias estaduais e
municipais pelo brasil inteiro
são mais de 30 mil inscritos e centenas
de pessoas espalhadas por todo o brasil
e hoje eu consegui criar um processo
seletivo que quebra todos os paradigmas
que eu tanto questionável do mercado
a gente não tem idade limite não têm
curso específico e não precisa vir da
faculdade a e b pra gente o que é
importante é um potencial que cada um
tem
hoje a gente tem treme de 22 a 34 anos
de biologia engenharia do norte ao sul
do país ea gente também fez ações
afirmativas da questão racial porque
essas pessoas têm oportunidades
diferentes e partem de pontos partidas
diferentes
isso tem que ser levado em conta o
equilíbrio entre homens e mulheres
também já foi uma questão e hoje 55% da
rede são mulheres
as pessoas trans terem o direito de
utilizar o nome que elas escolheram pra
si é o básico e hoje quando olha para os
nossos programas de formação
eu tenho certeza que a gente já está
desenvolvendo as pessoas que estão
transformando o país seja dentro da
gestão pública onde elas estiverem
porque essas trajetórias não vão ser
lineares
cada um vai encontrar sua forma
o seu caminho o dia 31 de dezembro de
eu estava passando no novo com os pais
na praia e uma treme ligou a câmera eu
vou desistir do programa
isso não tem nada a ver comigo eu fiz
engenharia trabalhar com gestão pública
não tem nada a ver
eu tenho pavor de falar em público e
semana que vem tem a formação eu vou
desistir
a gente conversou bastante e ela
resolveu se desafiam hoje ela trabalha
no governo com o projeto super
inovadores e as palestras fazem parte do
dia a dia dela foi preciso ajudar ela
romper com esse rótulo pra enxergar um
potencial que sempre teve uma novos
rótulos vão ser criados todos os dias ea
gente vai precisar ter muita atenção
para conseguir rompê los
vai ser uma luta diária na minha
trajetória foi muito importante conhecer
outras pessoas
houve pontos de vista diferentes de
paciência e romper com esses rótulos
como diria o jovem do começo é só uma
questão de tempo
hoje um acordo todos os dias com a
missão que mais pessoas compram esses
rótulos que foram impostas a elas
enxergam o potencial transformador que
têm cada um que afinal é transformando a
gente mesmo que a gente vai conseguir
transformar o mundo hoje para muito além
de uma mulher a psicóloga com menos de
30 anos empreendedora
eu sou o que eu nasci pra ser eu mesmo
consciente que todos os dias eu vou ter
novas fotos para romper
e você qual o rótulo que vai romper hoje
brigando
[Aplausos]